and we spoke to about a dozen all people
walking around on the street picked at
random and all of them told me they were
going to vote labor this isn't a labor
stronghold seat but only one person
actually knew who kirst armor was so
that was um quite an interesting litmus
test
um perhaps but on policy and that is
what a lot of people want to see from
kirst armor he talked about a Devolution
Bill to get power out of London he
talked about a long-term plan for energy
he talked about repealing anti-strike
legislation that the government are
talking about but on strikes there was
no Clarity on how they would deal with
the issue of pay particularly nurses
paid that is what a lot of people want
to see the government are calling this a
botched reboot here's James cleverley
the foreign secretary well what the
Prime Minister put forward were five
very clear measurable goals that we will
pursue in government and we can be held
to account for what we saw from Kia
starma as I say was a whole load of
nothing no firm commitments the only
commitment he did make was one that he's
already broken he said that he wouldn't
go reaching for the checkbook but we've
already seen 90 90 billion pounds worth
of unfunded spending commitments from
the labor party that will have to be
found through taxation of ordinary
people that works out about three
thousand three thousand pounds per
family so the only thing we did hear
from that speech was a complete
contradiction about Labor's spending
plans
so I think what we saw from care
Starbucks was an attempt to strike the
balance between criticizing the
government and also strike an optimistic
tone he talked about his pride in the
British public the faith he has he said
there is light at the end of the tunnel
he knows that the stakes are high that
he needs to cement Labor's polling lead
um but it does feel I have to say you
know year and a half two years out from
a general election like both Rishi sidak
and kirstmer are starting to get on
Election footing starting to get in
campaign mode and another day another
speech from a leader as I say his
emphasis that he is a candidate for
change